can you talk about your casting process
how are you approaching actors are you
reaching out to people's managers or
agents I love to cast I love to write
the script knowing who the actors are
with the 21 actress we have for season
two I think we had 12 of them cast while
I was writing the way I approach actors
who were out of my league let's like
Marcia Wallace any winter on the bub
Newhart show on The Simpsons I acted
with her and kind of a pilot
presentation thing a long time ago we
had mutual friends who were how I ended
up there and when I was writing the
mother-in-law part it's another
screenwriting trick that if you cast
even if you were never going to get
these people if you cast your roles even
though you're writing a spec feature but
you cast them with the actors who you
imagine playing these roles it at least
for me and I think for a lot of other
writers to hear that voice makes the
dialogue better makes the writing better
and because you already you're not it's
not just words because because of the
classic screen writing exercises to room
room of all the character names and you
should be able to tell the care whose
character that is just by the dialogue
and I think part of the part of making
that process is casting but with marcia
wallace in the back of my mind when i
was writing season one was maybe I could
get marcia wallace and then after it was
done like I guess I should go ask
Marshal Paulus and working on another
web series super deluxe series called
power loafing that was written by mike
upchurch who's
Chris Rock Show he had Neil Patrick
Harris come in his guest spot and the
way they pitched it to Neil was we need
you for four hours and and we had him in
and out in exactly four hours no plenty
breathing room meal time no rush refresh
but four hours and so when I got in
touch with Marcia I said look I've
written this thing kind of written it
with you in mind would you take a look
at this so she looked at the script and
she said I usually don't do this kind of
stuff but I love this part this is
really funny and I say only need you for
four hours because she thinks I lie
because every filmmaker is going to go
over everybody goes over everybody goes
wrong nobody makes their day when they
talk about four hours so when she came
in we got her in or not four hours Chris
Mulkey I'm boardwalk empire been on Twin
Peaks Chris and I need you for four
hours got him in and out for hours
Kirsten banks not same thing so once
you've done it a few times then when you
approach people for season two and I say
I said to marcia i'm going to 48 hours
she believes me she already knows how we
do things we didn't have a casting
director ever we did talk to a couple
casting breakfast for one part cuz we
chased a big fish for a long time that
we didn't get a great thing to do is go
see and sound ridiculous but go see
theatre in la is a million theater
companies as a million black boxes
because you can find actors watching
them work like I cast some people I told
them you have it you have a part I just
want you to come in and read for two
parts I'm not going I'm not saying you
or not I'm senior in this project I just
don't know which one you're going to be
I did that with some some roles but
almost everybody I'd never have
auditions for any of the parts almost
everyone was cast out
people I'd seen a stage at the rustboro
theater some John calella who's the lead
and co-producer on the show he had been
directed by Ray Allen in
italian-american reconciliation and
answer no so he approached her and she
had already seen the show at the
premiere which we had at the ruskin so
she saw season one and she knew kind of
what we were up to so it was a lot
easier to get a tony-winning award actor
who's been on The Sopranos and a million
other things so I I think that's one
thing if you want to get a name actor
and can find some other way other than
through an agent or manager that helps
but also it just casting in general see
some plays Tracy plays with may be
larger casts definitely the cafe plays
if you're in Los Angeles of the rust
group theater you can see you know 10
actors that are doing completely
different things in one night I think
that's a big thing and then
pre-production like I said I try to
write to a location you know so like
john john cleland Ramey hall or married
in real life and their real kitchen in
the show is the real kitchen real life
that was easy boom done their dog Shiloh
is the dog in the show so that was easy
because bring the dog and furnish it
with the dog a friend of mine lives in a
castle and the hills and I had already
written the scene with Chris Mulkey and
she's worked on a project together and
she was like would you like to shoot in
my house and I was like she said they've
been a castle and I'm like mean you live
in a castle and gonna looks like a
castle there's like a 25-foot stone
tunnel walk completely around and and uh
so Chris Mulkey he was selling blood out
of a castle somebody else said hey if
you need any cars I have a bunch of cars
and I'm like what kind of car
when I have a Bentley a Maserati a
couple of Jaguars of Rory and I'm like
I'll take the Bentley and just drop that
into the scene a really good thing to
watch if you haven't seen Christopher
Nolan's a short well slightly short
feature called following the audio
commentary on that is like a film school
because that was he said his make the
main characters a apartment was that
actors apartment he would shoot up from
rooftop of the actors on the street with
them laughed because you don't need a
permit if you're up on the roof shooting
down to them on the street so once you
start thinking like that I think it
helps with pre-production I think it
helps with writing tried it when I'm
writing I'm like how am I going to shoot
this like I just wrote a scene there
were only two locations I didn't have
which we found God while we were poor in
production always a little dangerous but
there was there's one thing that I've
written now that I'm like I don't know
where I'm going to shoot that so I'm
already I'm not even done with the
script and pre-production is essentially
already started because I already know
there's one location I don't have all
the other locations i have so far and
other ones i can see where they're going
to be but that's try to think of all
your friends where they live their yards
their garages their gyms their their
friend there's a restaurant what are
those restaurants hours all that kind of
stuff if you can it's early in the
writing processes you can start
pre-production for that kind of stuff
that will make your life so much easier
because if I wrote it's in a castle now
I have to go find the castle if I just
right I don't really know where this is
and somebody says hey do you want to
write the castle the exterior castle
dude we're in a castle so I think that's
a big part of it and the other thing for
pre-production the way I approach
shooting is
I hate the mockumentary thing which is
what we are to some extent it was a way
to introduce the story and break it but
it's also an approach to shooting I
shoot three cameras running at all times
as much as i can because its coverage
it's fast i can get my reverses i can
pick up stuff that if I was just doing
single look at single it makes
continuity so much easier and make
shooting a lot easier because if I can
light 360 and I've got two or three
cameras running then I don't need to do
a setup for this reverse instead of for
this it speeds up the whole process and
but to try to shoot something that is
visually appealing like watch stuff that
you liked even if you don't like the
movie with a TV show and you like what
it looks like look at it really look at
what is this frame where where are they
cutting just to kind of get that stuff
in your head for me because we don't I
don't do the proper George of
photography I don't we just kind of drop
cameras and I go how about this and this
you got this this and this good go has
been up time and real basic lighting and
don't try not to write something right
like we shot an action thing and jam
Brian and Dan speaker with white
choreographers came in and helped us
kill a couple of guys without canonical
guys but I wrote it so I knew I could
shoot it without any help like I try not
to write something that is so far out of
my ability that I have no idea how to
shoot it unless I absolutely have to
because that's another part of
pre-production if you can just keep
stuff I know where this location is I
know we can get this this actor I've
already have in my head all those things
as you're cooking it it all sort of
becomes one process and pre-production
can be less of it the script is done now
let me go find every one of these
locations now let me cast every one of
these parts if I already have people in
my head and locations in my head that I
think we're attainable or no or Tamil
they will make all pre production
everything so much easier I
you